I love this guy I always enjoy running
into him whenever I get a chance to chat
with him like just right now Black
Monday season 2 premiered this past
Sunday on Showtime at 10:00 Eastern Time
in his role of Maurice momen rogue
garnered him an Emmy nomination for his
season 1 in 2019 he is the
oscar-nominated actor Don Cheadle how
are you dawn up on the floor crying I'm
fine come on life in general that you
shows called Black Monday and the
markets are really tanking that sort of
thing I mean there's some bright side
right I mean at least we did pretty say
that I know that I know that but I guess
you know we can go down a little bit of
the the sports wormhole a little bit and
have a little bit of that sort of
distraction in a way you know yeah you
know it so now are you are you a Brady
fan at all Tom Brady fan at all or you I
mean Tom yeah like personally right I'm
yeah but I could never ever be a
Patriots fan so you know by association
I had to pull him into that you know
whirlpool of that's a great fantasy team
name whirlpool of distaste I do like
that one that's not a bad one because
you're a Bronco you're a bronco guy
right Don that's correct
I'm I mean I was born in Kansas City I'm
literally I still have a lot of family
there I moved to Denver so I always have
these sort of AFC you know internal
struggles but when the Chiefs play the
Broncos I routed sheep so that so you
must have been beyond ecstatic this past
oh yeah great it was great I was in
Hawaii at the time and I actually had
tickets and I gave my tickets to a
friend and he went to the Super Bowl and
I got to live vicariously through him
but it was a it was amazing to watch
yeah yeah I know I mean 50 years in the
waiting
so who was your who
your guy growing up from the Chiefs who
was that guy that you were rooting for
for the Chiefs when you were well I just
kept rolling through every you know
iteration of the team it was it was more
about the team it was when Montana came
over I was like really I was like whoa
Wow
you know it's amazing how when you get
new players from other places you go
from hating them to being like oh that's
my guy now so it just kind of became a
rotating roster yeah I know that there's
no you know natural distaste for the
Patriots maybe from Tampa Bay Bucs am
but if there is now they're like oh this
is the greatest thing ever in the same
way that you were looks like that for
Montana you know in its gates it's kind
of just like that yeah I was surprised
by that I guess I wasn't surprised by
that when you look at all of the what
you know all the ancillary stuff that he
can potentially do there now but you
know you and I grew up when Tampa Bay
was like you wouldn't touch to have a
like no way no those creamsicle uniforms
and the record the one win Lee Roy
Selmon creamsicle uniform guys and now
here comes time here comes Tom Brady you
know down the pike you know so what what
is your other what do you I forget Don
well what are your other sports that you
you're you're into pay attention to like
what are what are those you know I sort
of it's funny I kind of I became more a
workaholic and the kids are going to
school just I lost so much time
couch time sitting focusing on teams
that I still love the game you know I'm
in LA I love the Lakers I you know I was
very much you know when I went to
college and we would buy a TV to watch
the playoffs and then return it after
the playoffs that was my era of being a
rabid fourth man you know Showtime era
for the Lakers you know I'm back now
because the person you know I'm friends
with LeBron but I just went three
different cycles of like kind of being
out of sports really just watching the
game for just a love of the game
but not really diehard about anything
all right so there's you you said a lot
there Don to unpack first things first
is how does one return a television that
has clearly been used can you walk me
through that caper that you pulled off
Don because it actually was completely
fine you know Circuit City Best Buy all
of these places you could return the TV
within 30 days so you know we were good
we just get through the finals and we'd
be like okay he picked it feed me back
give any old reason why you were good so
did you give the reason that the NBA
finals were over or you you yeah about
it and see what people would say and you
know off and they'd be like word night
right yeah and then LeBron how did you
first cross paths with him you know at a
game and just did other things and the
party here there or whatever and then we
you know work together so that was kind
of cool it's been a lot of time with the
net which which for those who may not
know when did how did you work with him
where which okay Space Jam to what can
you tell me about LeBron on that's a Don
LeBron on that set was it was great
because he really is a probe and him
stepping into a real role and actually
having to anchor a movie you know he
just had a great work ethic and never
complained and you know movie set or not
the famous
nothing is playing ball here it's 14
hours sometimes lot of downtime rather
repetitive stuff a lot of just you know
you've done it it's just it's very
different than what he was used to but
he's there was no sort of lag time he
just dropped into it he's really good in
it
it was I love to see how serious he took
it and he wasn't he didn't come on like
the diva and you really could have been
pretty didn't at all he was just playing
on said yeah that's great to hear and we
word was that he did in fact have a
basketball court that was there for him
to make sure that his regular job could
be attuned and had attention to it so
was he out there also in the downtime
getting his work in on that front - well
you know on the downtime when you're
working on the set you kind of have to
sit there because you know at any minute
taking that I thought they were ready
for you right and you got it
come on but he was you know very 100
about his his sort of the physical work
that he had to do he was always being
worked on he was always know had to eat
at certain intervals he was very kept
his body in shape and he was still kind
of you know dealing with that injury was
recovering from a riot right um so it
was he was always in the process and
when we would you know play for the
movie you know here there would be
different gears of LeBron play you know
which was interesting to watch - what do
you mean battery well you know you can't
you know can't go full-out sometimes and
then sometimes they need you to go full
out right a couple times you know and
try to figure out how to modulate that
and it was I was always nervous any time
he went full out I was like please do
not hurt yourself on this movie and have
to like go explain it through the Lakers
organization right Oh
season's over because I I love that Don
Cheadle here on the Rich Eisen show we
were just talking about that movie for
some reason just the other day because
we always like watching sports movies
years later to see the cameos to see you
know who was the stars of the day in
that era so the original Space Jam like
said ceballos was in it Sean Bradley was
in it Mugsy Bogues you know was in it so
I just kind of dig you know what what
that might look like 10 20 years from
now when Space Jam 2 is ages right if it
will age that respect and what's amazing
is they can really with you know the
ability to interface replace and do CGI
the I don't I don't know what the movies
gonna look like I don't know who's gonna
be in it because I'm not sure if I'm
gonna be anything I think I think you'll
be in it Don Cheadle
so what is your role in it then I can't
rich we just went through this I can't
say anything else top secret too much
okay so much I don't get you any trouble
alright let's talk about Black Monday
here and and how you know sign of the
times interesting about what what the
show is about and and what fans should
expect from season two I'll give you the
floor on that dawn well I think you know
the the great thing about season two is
it you know continues to capitalize them
what happened in season one which is you
know just insanity and ending the season
with the crash and starting season two
with sort of the fallout and where we
find all of these players now and we're
sort of spread to disparate ends of the
of the world financial world and some of
us they're dealing with politics right
now there's some of us are still you
know dawn taking over the firm Mo's on
the run because you defeated it from the
law you know Pete talk shares characters
out there living his best life so we've
kind of blown it up in a good way I
think and you know it's trying to figure
out how to get the team back together if
they're going to get back together
wasn't gonna be like when they get back
together what's the talk to the D
toxicity level gonna be like when they
get back together pretty high well in
the cast is amazing we've had Paul
Scheer on the show he's a die-hard
clipper fan and you know Andrew Rannells
Roisin Regina Hall Ken Marino is one of
the most talented karaoke singers I've
ever personally witnessed in my entire
life Don I know if you've ever sung his
game on that front no we got to do that
we never depth never got to karaoke with
him he is truly one of the most talented
people I've ever met
and been around know that guy he's
amazing in the show and plays you know
twins in the show at the watch him go
through a theme playing all one side and
then playing all the other side and
having to act with himself but you know
a stand with the tennis ball on top of
well Black Monday a tremendous show
check it out on Showtime at 10:00
Eastern Time obviously many of us
of nothing but time on our hands because
we're all practicing the smart thing of
staying home if we can and social
distancing and sitting back it's a great
way if you haven't caught up on season
one to do that in advance of season two
that's up and running here man you're
you're you're one of my favorite follows
on Twitter to Don you keep doing what
you're doing
always good movie bump into each other
out there let's make it more to have it
you got it you last one for you a lot of
guys around here want to know if we've
seen the last of war machine I again
these are things I could talk about but
they have like this weird tracking
ability to alright just you know that
folks want to know Don I just we don't
we don't need any trouble for you that's
all we just want to make sure
everything's good for you you're you're
you're good man Don great to call great
to have you on the show and let's let's
keep in touch okay back atcha there's
Don Cheadle at Don Cheadle on Twitter
and Instagram